[Music]
the Internet is trying to figure out
who's the hottest Jonas brother so let
me ask you who's the hottest Jonas
brother Frankie Frankie ha ha
find it all you want Joe but there's no
denying the friendly competition between
Joe and Nick Jonas when it comes to the
gym are you putting in extra work so
baby bro doesn't you know outdo yet I'm
not really I mean um I think for both of
us we obviously like to Train but we're
in the gym together it's just a
different thing we have favorites that
we like to do but every once in a while
we'll try to bump it up and like go at
it still there's nothing but love
between these brothers and these days
Joe and his band dnce are spreading the
love with new single kissing strangers
all right Joe tell me what's a like
kissing Nicki Minaj huh oh I wouldn't
know it didn't happen but I was may it
look like it almost happened yeah you
know obviously we like to tease people
on and I think that's part of the fun
there's no smooch in that no smidge
smooching on Nicki Minaj well we will
have performances live saucy in the
meantime the band is challenging fans to
kiss some stranger's of their own by
sharing their own take on the song
through the musically app as for their
own smooching well we got the band to
kiss and tell what's one word each of
you would describe used to describe your
first kiss embarrassing
what's a good rule of thumb when it
comes to kissing stranger gum your
favorite kisser a band kiss a famous
stranger you'd like to kiss Miami camel
Penelope Cruz and me have some
unfinished business
Dania correct she stole my answer out
you